does anyone actually enjoy cutting grass
shoveling snow or raking leaves okay no
shade if you do but in case you don't
let me introduce you to yarbo this is a
robot that not only will mow your lawn
but it will also clear snow and leaves
what's also really cool is it's modular
so you can design it to fit your needs
this also means that it's ready for any
future upgrades that they may release
for it it uses GPS and magnetic field
navigation with 4G LTE connectivity that
you can control in the app to plan and
track your little long robot friend in
real time with its high resolution
camera now I definitely need to get this
for my dad because I uh I live in Los
Angeles and I don't have a lawn well I
do but it's fake grass